the king is here it really is a wild  eyeful regular-season game LeBron James  the Lakers and the youthful rockets but  this team is dangerous because of their  ability to score should be certainly a  fantastic show  [Applause]  don't man dominate one two three  [Applause]  Lance Stephenson get on it  23  I love to taste that the Lakers are  playing with right now both teams  looking for their  for the decision al Augusta Magan  there's the reigning MVP James Harden  good-looking shot look at the confidence  Lakers don't try to climb the bow  [Applause]  budgets are gonna be subsys pensioners  who's died  a poet cleans it up and throws it down  and judges make some pay the Rockets go  up five art steps back puts up a three  and goes  taps a breathing room  grit buckets 236 points James who's  pulled a few spoiled by the Houston  Rockets I'm saying that we're gonna have  some early struggles in the by said is  gonna be easy  [Music]